[Música]
ah
hola en este vídeo navegaremos juntos a
través de canacar m comenzando con el
inicio de sesión en la plataforma y
recorriendo todas las interfaces del
botón de navegación
[Música]
si ya estás registrado haz click en
iniciar sesión e ingresa con tu correo
electrónico y contraseña
si la olvidaste puedes recuperarla
haciendo clic en olvidaste tu contraseña
y sigue los pasos para recuperarla si no
has creado una cuenta y necesitas ayuda
para hacerlo te invitamos a que leas el
artículo que preparamos para ayudarte en
este curso una vez que hayas ingresado
entrarás al panel de profesores puedes
configurar tu página de inicio en
configuración más adelante veremos cómo
hacerlo en esta página hay tres botones
importantes el botón cursos que muestra
nuestro contenido dividido por
componentes curriculares el buscador
donde podrás encontrar contenidos
rápidamente el logo de khan academy que
lleva a la página de inicio elegida para
poder acceder a un menú con otras
opciones tenemos el botón de navegación
arriba del lado derecho justo donde dice
tu nombre
[Música]
una de las opciones del menú que se
despliega del botón de navegación lleva
la página de inicio del estudiante es la
página de inicio de los alumnos por lo
que las actividades asignadas por el
profesor se destacan en la parte
superior el menú vertical a la izquierda
permite navegar por los cursos que está
tomando el estudiante y ver su avance en
cada contenido al hacer clic en
profesores el estudiante puede usar los
códigos para formar parte de alguna
clase este código se genera en el
momento de la creación de la clase y
siempre aparece en el lado derecho de la
página de la clase al volver a hacer
clic en el botón de navegación puedes
elegir la opción panel del profesor
encontrarás tres pestañas muy
importantes la pestaña clases muestra
todas las clases que has creado en la
pestaña estudiantes encontrarás la lista
de todos los usuarios que tienen como
profesor la pestaña recursos incluye
algunos materiales que te pueden servir
para tener un mejor uso de la plataforma
y encontrarás también
un atajo para dirigirte al curso de
formación inicial de vuelta al botón de
navegación podemos encontrar el panel de
padres donde puedes agregar a tus hijos
y crear las cuentas también podrás dar
seguimiento al avance que llevan con las
actividades que realizan en la
plataforma en el menú de configuración
puedes editar la información básica de
tu cuenta restablecer tu contraseña
saber qué cuenta vía correo electrónico
está vinculada al acceso a khan academy
seleccionar tu página de inicio y más es
importante verificar si la función
profesor-tutor está seleccionada ya que
solo así tendrás acceso al panel de
profesor en la pestaña ayuda tendrás
acceso a una página llena de recursos
sobre khan academy además puedes contar
con nuestro equipo de soporte para
resolver cualquier problema técnico que
surja finalmente tenemos el botón
finalizar sesión para salir de la
plataforma para obtener más información
sobre khan academy visita el centro de
ayuda y consulta nuestra sección de
preguntas frecuentes